so about five years ago I had this
experience and not too far from here a
couple hours and in the redwood forest
it was in a deep meditative state
overnight and there was a full moon
night with fog going through the redwood
forest this misty called
the smell of the redwoods does that make
yeah yeah so it's just like and there's
a fire going on and I'm and I'm suddenly
having this experience of just like a
completely different presence around me
and and like when I close my eyes I
would see different types of blue lights
around me and I'm thinking wow I don't
know what's going on here but I started
like in my ear I hear no more birds or
insects like it's all dampened it is if
I'm like in a soundproof room and I
start to hear this voice of these light
beings talk to me and they say you know
you finally come to a place where we can
work with you what's up everyone welcome
to simulation I'm your host Alan sake on
super excited to be talking about
alignment within we have a seal talk so
joining us on the show
hi Ellen thank you so much for coming on
thank you for having me
those who don't know seals background he
is a channel and healer focused on the
evolution of consciousness in humanity
he can find his links in the bio below a
seal talk so calm as well as the
Facebook profile I'm super grateful to
Samantha Stein for helping not just to
make this happen indeed let's start
things off with one of our favorite
questions to ask our guests
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world hmm well it's definitely a
very interesting time to be alive and
one could say this at all the times that
humanity was alive but from my current
perspective it's it's a wild ride I have
I see extreme polarities and I see the
full spectrum of extremes that we're
having from wealth to poverty from
awareness to ignorant from healthy to
unhealthy from technology to non
technology so we have so many extremes
that maybe we've never had in human
history before and at the same time we
are more connected than we have ever
been so everything is much easier and
quicker accessible than it has ever been
in person or digitally so despite all
these things that we have we're doing
great things and we're doing
not-so-great things there's a lot of
struggle and challenges happening and I
may argue that those struggles all root
from a misalignment within
yes that first principle of know thyself
and have that divine connection to soar
spirit God all that is nature mm-hmm
that's the first principled issue right
any misalignments there have every
second order third order issue happen
afterward yes that's the way I see it
and my experience has been the outside
influences in the circumstances were
always an easy scapegoat for me to blame
what's happening to me always
considering oh I am the victim of my
upbringing I'm the victim of my
education I'm the victim of the society
I'm the victim of the system I'm the
victim of all these things like of my
heritage I'm the victim of my past lives
I'm the victim of my karma and
eventually I thought well I can't
continue living life by blaming
everything around me and trying to
escape from everything around me because
there is no escaping and eventually I
started to realize all right well let me
see how much of it is really outside and
how much of it is really inside and it
really just resonates in a certain way
that it becomes really visible to me
directly in front of me so assuming that
all the things that are happening to me
are a mirror reflection of what's
happening inside already and with that
just very basic realization I had I
come on a journey of self-discovery of
self-realization really diving deeper
and deeper and deeper in words and
trying to see where how am i creating
the reality that's around me and how are
we as a collective creating the reality
that we currently have I love this
mirror it's very important and the
essence being that what we see in our
perspective is mirror is a mirror of
what's happening within yes so on an
individual level definitely true but
also collect on a collective level
definitely true so the shadows or the
misalignment or the challenges that we
have internally and one could say also
Karma that we have requires to be
digested processed in some form and
turned into a realization or a piece of
wisdom and that's a process that takes
some time it's a digestive process and
that process happens internally but it
also happens as a collective
consciousness because we are not
necessarily separate we're having
individualized experiences but we're
part of the same field of consciousness
and so it is my responsibility to also
be part of your realization and it is my
responsibility to be part of the
collective's realization but I believe
that my highest leverage point of
assisting with all of that is this one
right might take a lot of time to change
someone else maybe it's impossible one
might say and internally it might be
difficult but it feels like the highest
leverage point of action
yes
I want to know how we digest karma mmm
what does that mean and how do we do
that
that's a good point I think before we
even get into various terms that require
you know big definitions and you know
there's different definitions and
different lineages and religions and so
on if we just look inside and see all
the ways that our mind operates our part
our emotions operate and our system our
physical body operates and then there is
also the operations of spirit and soul
we can see that some things are just not
going the way it should be something
feels off slightly off something might
feel off in interaction with other
people or something might trigger me in
a certain way in all various ways these
systems speak to us right so there is
like the inner chatter that speaks to me
the emotions speak to me my body speaks
to me when I listen to it right and when
it's really quiet our own spirit our own
consciousness speaks to us as well so
first step is really to understanding
what are all my parts saying what is
that voice that's coming from different
places so the first step is to read this
user's manual of the body
yeah or more like a status quo a check
in an internal chicken what does that
look like what does a internal check-in
look like yeah yes yes and it may not be
pretty
in the beginning and anyone who's gone
on this journey knows it can be messy it
can be tough it can be very raw and
vulnerable
but I do believe it's very important for
every individual to have that internal
look and to start there yes you love
this this internal check and you spend
so much of our lives on focused on the
external world and so I love this this
like internal check-in and we check in
for our vehicle gets the oil changes and
all this type of stuff gets checked in
all the time but to treat ourselves like
someone that we are responsible for
taking care of is a good way to view it
as well so ok so this internal check-in
there's this there's this mind there's
this heart there's this gut there's the
spirit or the soul you know so what are
these parts when we do this check-in
what our how to check into these parts I
think there is an aspect that requires a
silence some sort of silence
contemplation and the first and most
dominant aspect of our being is
currently our mind just because it's the
structures that we have established
require our minds to be very active so
it is the one that has kind of taken the
driver seat which means in the beginning
when we start to sit it's gonna be the
one that's the loudest mmm right and
then there are certain phases where the
emotions or the heart is the loudest
it's like something happens in a
relationship that just brings up a
certain type of emotion or a certain
emotion is the press suppressed for so
long that it explodes and the right
trigger and then the body right we work
out we try to take care of it in a
certain way but sometimes we ignore it
and that will start speaking
and it requires that moment of silence
to really hear all of it
and when it's really silent once the
mind and the emotions in the body are
becoming into a place of you know
quieting down while you're still
conscious and awake there is an aspect
of the soul that starts to speak and
that may take some time for some people
and for some it goes quickly but
ultimately that check-in is what are the
thoughts and emotions that are currently
going through my system what are the
basic needs that are unmet what are the
deeper underlying needs that are unmet
maybe needs from childhood and then
sometimes there are aspects of our being
that we can't even explain why they're
part of this lifetime
so we may start to inquire is there some
sort of even older need that was not met
or an older situation let's say of past
lives or one could say it's an aspect of
the collective that we individually
start to tap into that comes to us for
processing right because we're available
and we can do it
so this is what I would say now I don't
think we need to fix these things
immediately
just because we're listening to it I
think observation is the first and most
important step interesting just to gain
awareness as an observer correct and
then we will start to observe the same
thing in many different perspectives not
just from the perspective of the wounded
or the you that identifies as you you
start to see it from other places and
other
and many many different perspectives and
observations start to digest what has
happened or what is happening currently
so that's one of the ways of deepening
that understanding of the self and the
different aspects that we have
okay so for this inward check-in we aim
to become more of an observer and we
notice likely our mind is the loudest
and it is attempting to remind us of
this appointment that we have or this
task to execute that we must do this
person to reply to and the more that we
work on just bringing it back to just
trying to check in may be inward and
just being aware that the mind is racing
to all of these other things being more
aware that it's just racing to those and
being aware of the the heart in how it
can call up an emotion so suddenly with
there may be a trigger how the physical
body will speak when it's not being
properly taken care of mm-hmm okay and
then in once we get we're checking into
those and we're quite a quieting this
inner chatter a little bit then we may
have an opening for this soul spirit
this higher self correct and the higher
self is doing what is it doing with you
what is it doing with other people that
you've worked with what is that how does
that come in
I think it first for me it would bring
underlying needs of my spirit of my soul
that wanted to be digested processed and
this was more than just emotions it was
deep in old relationships or it was what
are like deep longings that I have that
I can't really explain and I would start
to listen and start to follow that
without necessarily questioning or
judging how silly it is or what might
other people think and so on so just to
follow that for a bit and see what comes
up so it's a journey like listening to
that Higher Self and it may first
require to do a couple of steps of
surrendering to it and really listening
deeply and I think eventually we come to
a place where there is a certain
equilibrium of all the different parts
they know they're being listened to so
they behave more and so the heart is
more settled the mind is more settled it
doesn't require to be a dominant figure
in this Roundtable
the body knows it's being taken care of
and the soul or the higher self knows
it's being listened to so we start to
walk life in a different way
and I can guarantee your people around
you will feel the difference you will
feel the difference this way that we
walk and behave and act when this
settled alignment has occurred makes it
so that yes friends family coworkers
people online or more or seeing some
sort of a transformation occurring and
then there's a maybe there's even more
of an alignment towards our our most
highest gifts that we can bring into the
world mm-hmm
and then it seems like we're more
connected with that North Star in those
gifts so I always like to use the
analogy of a garden and in some ways I
believe this internal alignment is
setting up a really nice fertile soil so
you're tending the weed you're making
sure your soil is loose as oxygen has
nutrients has water everything it needs
and that soil will eventually start
sprouting things that you don't even
know what it's gonna be and this is what
I perceive as the gift or maybe a or
many purposes life purposes that are
coming up and they will come naturally
based on that how well that soil has
been tended that make sense so it's not
really in in my perspective it is not
really trying to find oh I want to find
my life purpose now give it to me
without that groundwork I think it's
just another thing that we follow so
I remind myself if there is something
that I'm doing that does not feel a line
from all my parts have I tended to the
groundwork have I tended the soil
properly so that this can grow and if
it's not growing there's something wrong
with the soil does that make sense yes
alignment within makes the soil
conditions optimal for the seeds of the
gifts correct to grow correct now of
course with every soil there is also the
environment right so the earth provides
an environment which can be a difficult
environment sometimes to grow anything
and sometimes we may have to find other
spaces where our soil is much more
suitable for growing our gifts metaphor
still working so it may require
sometimes to change location or
perspective or a place where this
baseline that I have is much better
fitting the certain types of flowers and
plants grow only in certain parts of the
world as we align more within we then
realize that we may need a locational
shift around the world to a location
where this gifts can come forth and it
might not be just location it could be
circumstances saw people in our group
and network it could be community it
could be a tribe relationships mmm it
could be lifestyle mmm right all the
habits and behaviors that I've created
for myself for
a being that was operating beforehand in
order to achieve specific goals but now
if the goal is to achieve an equilibrium
or a fertile soil so to say of your
being what does that require what do I
need and really you're the only one that
can say I can give you a couple of tips
of healthy living and many people do but
ultimately it must sit within what's
right for you
I like this as the consciousness becomes
transformed and ascends that these
behavior patterns and maybe some of the
old soil that used to be there
that was maybe focused more on ego or
material or all these other things we we
do we reap a turn our habits we lay new
soil in a sense and so to to change
those friend groups to change those
locations in those habits and the new
ways of seeing maybe even D
materializing and these types of things
can can help that alignment really
rocket upward mm-hmm absolutely
and I do believe some of these
relationship changes or environmental
changes around you don't need to be like
conscious changes they happen to you
the moment you start changing the soil
almost your environment starts changing
yes and many people that have come
through transformational experiences
will will be able to confirm that how
relationships just started to fall off
or Newton relationships started to come
into their lives or certain habits that
they used to have don't really have that
same pool or the same energy anymore
does that sound familiar oh yeah yeah so
that's how you know you're in a
transformational journey
what but the observation is so important
that then if the habit is no longer
serving your transformation to be very
aware of that observation is so
important because that's what assists us
with that reap a turning of the habits
yes how many times I wonder because I
look at my life and I used to be this
hard working you know entrepreneur
executive really trying to achieve all
the things that society has told me my
parents have told me education has told
me and the structures that we have
created have told me this is achievement
this is success if you do this you're
gonna be good and how many times have I
really checked internally this is really
what I want and does this really feel
right or am I just being sold on a dream
right and upon a couple of these
achievements I would wonder why do I
still feel unhappy in the face of
achievement and success according to
right and I started to question things
and doubt things like maybe there's
something here that I don't know and see
I'm gonna start asking my own questions
and that's an interesting point yeah
because it can be a very depressing
point right who do you start who do you
believe and who don't you believe and it
could be at this illusion a moment of
all those people that I've trusted don't
know what I need to be happy so that's
another one of those awakening moments
from birth the indoctrination of the
parental teachings the education system
the government of the nation that you're
in the media propaganda is all
influencing the seed of the child as
it's being brought into the world and
when did when were we ever ever taught
about the check-in hmm mm-hmm
are these things aligned check-in or any
are these things aligned and it's so
important to have a trusted at least one
person trusted person because parents
are gonna have their own influence
mm-hmm you know certain friends you know
if you got to be careful if you say good
news to your friend are they really
genuinely loving and and yes the pie is
growing you're growing I love it or are
they you know secretly wishing bad
mm-hmm and so or same thing with who you
told bad news to are they wanting to
genuinely empathize and help you grow
and transform or are they secretly yes
so who is this this friend that you can
potentially have with your multiple
friends that can help the in to check in
and have that dialogue between for the
check in how is that check-in process
going where are you feeling it how is
the higher-self coming into play you
know all these questions to have at
least a one or a cup of people that are
trusted there
there's gonna be crucial for that soil
to become more fertile to have the gift
for sure I think an externalize
representation of that internal chicken
can be very helpful community a highly
aware individual partner family member
friend and this doesn't have to be a
lifelong thing it could be a momentary
thing it could be just one conversation
in the bus mm-hmm it could be a mentor
that oversees your growth for a period
of time it could be that one line that
you read in a book that's putting that
up for chicken right check in with
yourself like what's going on there and
so I believe that there is once you go
on this journey you will have a lot of
helpers a lot of support its support
everywhere even if that is the walk down
the street into the park nature will
support you it will reflect to you right
so there are so many ways we can receive
reflection again a mirror in a positive
way
all right an assistance in support of
our growth yes it's that's that's great
that that even a on a journey into
nature that we could as we are aligning
more within that we can see the
hummingbird go for a little bit of neck
we're like ah ah and so there's all
different the little dragonfly whizzes
by the little squirrel jumps from a
branch to another branch and the
sunlight shines just this beautiful way
through some trees and it's just there's
so many ways that nature speaks to us
along the path as well I love how you
talk about the support system so if
you--if we begin the process of aligning
with in the support systems come into
and also a good example of this I think
so many of us are so familiar with this
example but perspective being everything
you can be in the vehicle driving and
get just road rage or on this aligned
within path when we nurture that when
we're driving we can say oh maybe the
person is in an emergency to the
hospital all these different potentials
to be the case and so the same scenario
completely different perspective and
experience very well said very well said
so healthy support systems are maybe
required as we're still operating in
automatic behaviors and patterns right
if you know there are certain aspects
that are driving your being then I put
some things into place and I say you are
one of my closest people and I empower
you to reflect following things to me
when I'm out of line when I'm out of
integrity
I want you to support me no matter how
hard it is for me to hear it so who are
you in your life empowering you to be
clear and clean mirrors alright so this
is also a lot of that is nature is
always a clean mirror yes absolutely
nature is maybe the cleanest mirror as
long as we take care of it right so
quiet in nature is an incredibly
powerful mirror let's venture into this
journey for us so being born in Vienna
in Austria and to Turkish immigrant
parents and when did this young a seal
end up getting interested in this
spiritual path and and then it's been 18
years of this path now and five years
ago was a very important moment
correctly so let's take us through that
sure so I was always a little different
now a lot of probably our viewers are
having that same experience I was always
a little different right just a little
and being a you know trying to be put
into certain boxes that society has
created works you know until it doesn't
work anymore so I have because of the of
my upbringing I have taken on a certain
identity and a certain personality and I
have explored you know higher education
in so many different ways
entrepreneurialism and so on excelling
in those different aspects but it would
never give me this level of fulfillment
and I thought fulfillment or what the
general term happiness is even that's
not the emotion I'm talking about I'm
talking about a sense of feeling
holistic whole it wouldn't come from
these achievements they would only give
temporary relief right and so for me the
jury
was really I need to find all the ways
where I'm trying to fill holes in my
system with things outside you know that
one right so they would give temporary
relief and then you would look for the
next sparkly thing to fill that or the
next relationship to fill it and so I
started to look more into how am I going
to be able to fill these holes long-term
and sustainably maybe not forever but
long enough so that next time when I
look into it it's not like a gushing
wound and as I've been with this
curiosity it started of you know the
mystical path and the spiritual path and
I would start to look into all these
different lineages that had and the
different societies that had these
aspects ingrained in religious or
non-religious context so my curiosity
was very strong and I was not brought up
in any ways in a religious environment
rather very liberal and very you know
open to modernism hence why I'm an
engineer and scientist right by
education and so the curiosity of
spirituality was very high the curiosity
for the unknown was very high so I
started to seek out all these you know
different methodologies it started off
with meditation and looking into the
mystical path and I started to venture
out further and further and the furthest
I could go to shamans or to Masters in
Southeast Asia and Asia Far East Asia
and to teachers and shamanic mentors in
the Americas and South America and so I
would just go as deep as that they were
willing to take me
there was an aspect of I am scared
shitless but I'm gonna go because I want
to find out the answers not by you
telling me the story of where the answer
is but I want to experience it
experientially correct because I'm a
hardhead right I can rationalize
everything away I can rationalize
everything away the engineer in
scientist exactly so for me to be truly
embodying and embracing a certain truth
I have to experience that internal it
has to move something inside of me and
so I've been going all deeper and deeper
and deeper into some of these different
lineages started in Taoism and Buddhism
and shamanism and in also modern
psychological ways of transformation yes
even just those off the bad I mean so
important to study mm-hmm we've so much
hubris in this especially as a newly
formed Western world where we just
believe that the stimulation we're
getting from the media that we consume
on the platforms is this most important
content when the most important content
is really had the is experiencing the
Linde effect it's it was made thousands
of years ago and why is it still here
because it's that important and that's
what our some buddhism shamanism even
like you said even the moderate
psychologies have a lot to do with this
as well understanding neural signatures
understanding yeah but Vegas and there's
all different types of things that we've
only more recently the EMF of the heart
all this kind of crazy stuff so yes
please um continue taking visitor your
journey and lineages I'm just so happy
that you
this you did like a la carte buffet of
oh yeah of the most important stuff yeah
yeah and I would work with it
until I felt I've gotten a really good
gem from this and I can bow in gratitude
and I can move on and I can seek to have
a different perspective on what's going
on inside of me so the journey kept
going and at some point I was still I
was still running companies at that
point it was a parallel track of
spiritual exploration and mystical
exploration and you know doing the
things that society wants us to do like
running company having employees having
clients all that jazz right and I came
to a crossroad where one path was giving
me excitement curiosity or some pain but
ultimately an aspect of fulfillment
there was always forward movement I felt
like I'm growing on the other side I was
successful and I was being perceived as
very good in what I do but it was not
giving me the level of sensation of
fulfillment and growth and the sense of
that what I'm doing is actually making a
difference in my own world and also in
the general collective some of your
spiritual practices were coming into the
entrepreneurial and they were making it
more successful
sure absolutely but the most fulfilling
for you was shining the star of the
spirituality and then having that also
shine into other people's stars become a
murder
yes so what would happen is every time I
would just go through a milestone how if
you're like wow there is an expansion
that's happening inside of me and
sometimes I would try to impose it on
other people right I would like oh you
have to do this and you have to do this
this is amazing and of course sometimes
it works and sometimes it doesn't right
but ultimately I started to realize even
just alone me internally carrying this
expansion and this opening is making a
difference in the people around me they
act in react differently my relationship
to my parents transformed my
relationships in general transformed so
my relationship to myself transformed
even most importantly right
self-perception so I started to
understand okay I'm getting to a point
where I have to make a decision and if I
don't one side is gonna try to
continuously compensate for the other
side does that make sense so the
spiritual side giving me energy and
uplifting and continuation of growth the
other side feeling like what the hell am
I doing here spinning my wheels so I
chose instead of a path of pain and
depression to just jump off the cliff
and that's a key moment that many people
will experience were the unknown and the
uncertain and the potential change that
we're about to embark on might it will
take you on a ride and it may not be
easy your parents are gonna ask you if
you are out of your mind your community
is gonna potentially laugh at you and be
like dude what are you doing
and I'm just speaking out like the worst
case scenarios right and you may not
make as much money as you did before and
you may be struggling for a while you
may be in discomfort for a while but
ultimately there is always light at the
end of the tunnel so this continuous
work will you know when you are
preparing your garden there is nothing
in the beginning all you're doing is
weeding and preparing the soil there is
no fruits there is nothing to eat you're
just watching soil right you're
nourishing the soil but there is a
belief and there is a trust that
eventually something will come out of
this if I started to get better at every
step of the moment it can only result in
something monumental and beautiful for
me and through me for all those around
me yes experience years ago okay so
about five years ago I had this
experience and not too far from here a
couple hours and in the redwood forest
it was in a deep meditative state
overnight and there was a full moon
night with fog going through the redwood
forest this misty called the smell of
the redwoods does that make it yeah yeah
so it's just like and there's a fire
going on and I'm and I'm suddenly having
this experience of just like a
completely different presence around me
and and like when I close my eyes I
would see different types of blue lights
around me and I'm thinking wow I don't
know what's going on here but I started
like in my ear I hear no more birds or
insects like it's all damp
as if I'm like in a soundproof room and
I start to hear this voice of these
light beings talk to me and they say you
know you'll finally come to a place
where we can work with you hmm
and I'm thinking oh boy I think I'm just
now about to lose my [ __ ] so I'm
thinking maybe this was a little too
much transformation but I'm I'm amusing
myself with the thought of something is
going on here that I can't explain and
I'm gonna follow that path so they're
basically saying at that point I've been
already working for several years as as
a shamanic guide as a healer and
different methodologies and they're
basically saying I have to let go of all
the different lineages that I have
learned that have brought me to where I
am and they will work and prepare me to
do their work so as a vessel for their
work yes and at that point I don't even
know what their work is all I know is
like these reverent bright lights that
are with me that have such a presence
such a high frequency even like in my
ear I would hear this high-pitched sound
and I say okay well let me think about
it right so I think about it for a bit
and eventually I'm terrified by I
surrender to it and I go on this journey
with these light beings and on this
first date that I have with them the
same Eve the same in the in the redwoods
know this was a okay I took a couple
months to think about okay the
invitation was that either yes that was
the opening moment
were it was clear something is going on
in my field like there is something
sprouting off my garden
this isn't I didn't plan this right all
I prepared was the soil and now
something is coming off and I don't even
know what it is you know when a sprout
comes off you don't even know what land
it's gonna be so I'm here and I'm
thinking okay well this is gonna be
interesting
definitely a turn of events and you
accept and you go on this date several
months later and you weren't expecting
this date either well I kind of knew
that when I'm ready they'll be there
okay so I said okay well I'm I'm ready
let's do it what do we have to do so I
went on to some really deep states of
you know trans states in which I started
to connect with them closer and closer
and the first one that introduced
himself said greetings my name is
Emanuel and I thought man well maybe the
name of that person like you know a
saint or something like that and I said
is it manual and I said no it's a manual
okay after that I go on Google I look
for a manual and says there is an angel
called Emmanuel and I'm thinking okay
now I'm really losing my mind
like talking to angels like there's no
way my parents are gonna be accepting
that and my friends are definitely gonna
declare me crazy right so I'm this in
this internal conversation they're like
I can't talk to anyone about this
this has to stay a secret until I am
comfortable being able to talk about it
so and maybe I'm thinking maybe it's a
phase it'll go away so I keep on going
and there is many more of these dates
and connections and sessions and they
keep on working on my energetic system
and they keep on revealing more and more
of what their work is on this plane for
Humanity and it turns out that they have
a grand plan of assisting humanity
through its evolution the evolution of
its consciousness now they're saying
we're not here to fix your problems
that's still gonna be yours but we're
here to allow you to get to states where
you can see more perspectives where you
can get to know yourself better and with
that internal connection with internal
alignment all of your actions will start
to look differently and you can more
easily tackle these grand challenges
correct Sudi there was an opening up of
the catalog of of consciousness states
and possibilities and transformative
processes mhm and then you going through
the process of experiencing those and
then sharing those with other people
would uplift consciousness and challenge
or tackle those big challenge so in some
ways they have their own method of doing
that which is why they're utilizing me
as a vessel for their work right and
then you wonder if there's possibly
others being utilized for for sure for
light but also for dark absolutely
there's no doubt about it
there is all colors of the spectrum and
all shades of grey exist on our plane
without a doubt okay we can get into
that a little bit yes so in in in the
work that they have been doing it's like
how can because there's a lot of
individuals that deliver messages right
even from like higher planes and high
different forms of consciousness spirits
Dedes ascended masters there's a lot of
that going on now delivering a message
is not necessarily the biggest of what
they can do they're saying we're going
to deliver some sort of energetic
transmission and we're going to provide
some sort of alignment for all those
before we even speak so that the message
can land in a way that it's gonna make a
change and an impact in your life does
that make sense
so if we just sit here okay maybe you're
already a bit in an altered state and
I'm - right so messages are coming along
differently now but if we were just in a
coffee shop just regularly chatting and
I tell you hey you know like we've got
to do all these amazing things about
ourselves and out of the world
five minutes later you're already on
your tasks and like the things that you
have to do for the day
and out the door is the idea that you
needed to go to the gym take care of
your body and you know do meditation and
take care of all your relationships
right so when that type of work happens
when these energies work through me the
way they induce some sort of an altered
state in this space what is what makes
it possible for these messages to
actually land on a much deeper level in
the human consciousness or human psyche
so that it it starts to make a change
yes
and what were these dates that you went
on how what were these experiences like
with Emmanuel and and what were you
getting downloaded and it's a lot of it
was incredibly physical and physically
intense so I would say that in the human
body there is an energetic template
there is there are powers way beyond our
imagination that lies into one single
human being and they were starting to
activate these templates they were
working on various different energy
channels they were making sure that all
my organs and energy lines are working
optimally so that I can become that
vessel to not just transmit the energy
that comes but also collect and compress
just provide that for the space that's
around me and so in these sessions I'll
go into incredibly fast breathing and
shaking and it just looks wild like my
eyes will roll upwards and it's it's a
very intense thing even to just watch
it's intense for me or now I'm getting
used to it but there is an aspect of
ramping up the energy to the point where
I'm in this complete trance state and
and then I feel like one of them
basically taking over my body and
they're like going into different mudras
and they start to like look around and
scan every individual like what's going
on and I could see like from their
perspective everything from like the
outer fields all the way to the body and
the solids and the organs and even like
to the DNA and the ancestry it's just
becomes everything becomes so
transparent Wow yes and then they start
to work on all of these various aspects
of the individuals now what's
interesting is they operate in an
incredibly high integrity way meaning
they won't work on anyone that does not
want to be worked on period
even if someone is struggling
tremendously in their lives if they
don't want to be worked on they will
never be worked on it's their free will
to live their lives the way they want to
live their lives
that makes sense they will only work as
much as the individual can take at that
point without destabilizing their life
mm-hmm right how many destabilizing
transformational experiences have you
had I've had quite a few mm-hmm like
I've been in bed or in my room for weeks
to just digest what just happened now
it's not the experience that they want
to give to the participants
it needs to be able to move them but
they need to still be able to be
functional in their lives and their
careers and so on does that make sense
so it's a bit of a gentle approach but
still effective so that's what they're
trying to do and with this alignment
people going to people that have never
meditated before they're like wow I was
in this zone I've had these visions I've
had these voices you know people have
very interesting reports and what they
have experienced in these sessions and
then there is the spoken part where they
share aspects of wisdom a lot of it is
very simple very almost like a bird's
eye view non-dual wisdom at the same
time compassionate about whatever we're
going through and they'll speak about
the state of affairs
to look back and see how over thousands
of years there have been so many
experiences of ritual or ceremony of
trance of seance of so many ways of
connecting to what is spiritual or
mystical or beyond the physical reality
that once we open ourselves up more to
all of that lineage that's been
happening we no longer just binary label
things as like psychosis or neurosis or
psychopathy or whatever rather we open
ourselves up more to the possibility
that these are actually potentially
divine rituals and codes that have
significant
participation of our own alignment
within and also of our society's
alignment and so when you talk about
when you talk about your vessel being
able to have light that channels through
it to see other people's organs DNA life
journeys ancestors childhoods
all these different aspects of them I
think that awakens us to the sheer
complexity of every single one of us
that is present and how it's not just
this it's not just limited to the word
saunder where it's that our lives of
different complexities with families and
friends and co-workers and careers and
all this type of stuff but it's deeper
what is the heart state the brain state
the DNA state the gut state the lineage
the ancestor lineage the childhood
experiences all these things and the
divine purpose of that being joy all of
those things and to be able to see those
things and and be a source of further by
working on our own alignment our own
garden helping others work on their
alignment in their gardens
so then with these you have an upcoming
workshop on 15th
yes September in San Francisco so tell
us about then what happens at the
workshops how is that related to what we
were talking about with Emmanuelle and
all these other light beings that come
yeah so in a session that's between two
to three hours in its length I will go
into a trance and in this how do you get
yourself it's very much connected like
III sit and close my eyes and then it
just starts automatically like it's so
integrated almost like they know now
it's session time and it just starts and
it starts with contractions in my lower
belly and these contractions like
trigger like fast breathing yeah and
then there is like circular movements of
my spine it's like you know like waves
coming through and and then I start to
you know feel more and more in an
altered state and eventually the energy
will have built up so much and my
energetic state is in a place where they
can embody me and they control all my
upper body so all my gestures and you
know where I look and how I move is
controlled by the energy that's
embodying me and sometimes that's
Raphael sometimes it's Emmanuel or mica
al and so on and so when that happens I
am a bit of an observer like I'm far
away sometimes I don't even remember
what's going on or what is being said I
remember about half of it so they will
establish not just my own energetic
system but also the energetic system of
the space it has to be a safe space to
do healing and alignment right so just
like the surgery room
has to be hermetically sealed and clean
mm-hmm and so that is being done now the
individuals can sit or lie down it's
perfectly fine either way some people
will even you know fade out fade away
going to their own version of a
translator meditative States and people
will fall asleep we make sure they don't
snore but ultimately their presence and
their willingness to receive will just
allow them to do some work and there is
basically a lot of the work that I do
happens from where I sit and it will
look like very fast hand movements it's
almost like they're doing a surgery on
like different aspects of the individual
and it will go through the entire room
and if there is smaller groups I will
even go to every individual person do
like some work there so I'm mostly like
completely drenched because it's so much
physical aspect to it it's not that
subtle oh my being at least and and
there is a certain you know people
report that they hear that
high-frequency pitch people report that
they see different forms of the colours
of light when they close their eyes and
there is you know various different
levels of reports also depending on
people's sensitivity and people's
openness to see right yeah so that's the
first aspect and and there is a quality
of silence in the space it's really it's
really something I believe if that's
probably my top thing right it's the
quality of the silence how powerful it
is and how beautiful it is and then
there will be some sort of sharing that
they will do they will often share about
the times that weren't currently in
humanity year in history the importance
of the individuals journey similar to
the way I've spoken about it how the
individuals journey is the one that
impacts the entire collective if we get
every individual to start doing that
work Wow something is gonna shift and
they're also talking about how the times
that we're in are not necessarily gonna
get easier immediately
it's gonna get even more challenging and
how do you face external challenges is
by having an unwavering in strong core
and alignment with it right strong body
a solid heart clean mind and a strong
spirit all right so this alignment will
allow you to face challenge too no
matter what they are they're emotional
spiritual environmental right so this is
a basically saying start to look into
that it's gonna be this is gonna be the
thing you can hold on to right it's not
something you can fix with you know a
quick fix this is something that needs
to be nourished it's not something that
needs to be alkalized
and then there is an opening for
potential questions that people have so
we have you know in the in the years
I've been doing this I've done this work
everywhere around the world in Europe
and Asia in the Middle East there has
been a variety of questions that people
have asked about everything you can
imagine so eventually we're gonna
publish books with those channelings and
the answers or they're almost poetic
it's like really beautiful there's no
way I could be doing that because I have
zero bone in me that's poetic
so you get yourself into the trance
state other people are relaxing there so
some are in trance and we're laying down
some we're sitting and then you begin
the process of allowing the you by
trance you get the light beings come
channel through unit to the space make
sure it's sealed make sure that it's
most conducive for the alignment within
processes yes you even you even spend
some time in your seated position but
then you also stand up and go to some
corrective individuals they will
sometimes tell me to go to specific
individuals to do some work and because
everyone is in a different place in
their journey it's different for
everyone right for some people it'll be
more like subtle for some people it will
be much bigger and for some people it's
more on the physical level that's the
highest priority work for some people
it's on the spiritual level so and I've
had many practitioners of very like
long-term practitioners of different
lineages that would also come to just
experience something different and they
would have some work done that allowed
them to move faster and stronger in
their journey
so the beautiful thing about that I
pride myself with this work is that it
does not require any belief system it
does not require for you to change your
belief system or your methods or your
lineage like literally anyone can come
I've had babies couple weeks or tables
in the ceremony I've had 90 year old
people in the ceremony or in the
sessions and so it's really guided and
made in a way that's
fitting for every individuals current
moment and you described this as some
sort of a even a like a surgical process
for every single one no matter where
they're at if it's more physical more
spiritual let's visit so this is
happening these sessions happen every
month sometimes every month so depending
on where I am at
so there'll be I'll be on tour sometimes
in Europe I'll be on a tour in the
Middle East and depending on where I am
I do sessions in those particular cities
and then I come back to San Francisco
and I do sessions here sometimes where I
live in the house it's gonna be like
smaller groups you know anywhere from
ten to twenty five and then the bigger
groups 100 200 people okay and all the
information on the website or those for
the for the tour and for where you'll be
where does
our
relationship
with source God creation all that is
where does our relationship with how
does that relationship interplay with
free will and with determinism mm-hmm so
in my in my experience and this
connection to source creator exists all
the time as long as we're alive
it exists in fact everywhere around us
it permeates through everything and our
consciousness is certainly tied in some
way into all levels of consciousness all
the way to source now we are having an
experience in human form and in this
human form experience were allowed to do
whatever we want to do
technically so and and it won't even be
judged so it will be what it will be now
everything that we choose to do has some
form of effect cause and effect or
consequence sometimes the consequences
are for us sometimes the consequences
are for other people or the collective
and from these cause and effects and
consequences ideally we learn and so
each of these experiences no matter how
we judge them or as good or bad will
have some sort of underlying learning
and the important lesson within now
sometimes it's really hard to see the
lesson if you're going through a tough
time right and
ultimately I believe that all these
lessons that are deeply buried in all of
our experiences or sometimes easily
accessible that's the ultimate reason
for us to be alive
and as we experience individually and as
we experience as a collective human
consciousness grows it grows it expands
and we're coming to a place where human
consciousness is growing so much that
according to what is told to me
what is being channeled that humanity is
coming to a time and place where it will
move from this human form experience to
a more non material form experience
let's say to a different form of school
where the learnings and the teachings
are different and so this is what is
what they consider as the Ascension
process now it's I think fairly
different and I'm not very much in
theological studies so I apologize I
don't want to find anyone with this but
there is definitely some similarities in
the various religions with regards to
this ascension process but I think there
is also some fairly strong distinctions
and the way that is presented to me and
the this transformational stage that
we're in in human history is going to
require everyone to do their part and it
starts with this one
so we have
free will in the ascension process yes
we do and if you choose not to do
anything about your growth then all the
ones around you will carry you along but
if you choose to do something about it
it'll help you it'll help everyone else
so there is an aspect of it will make a
difference if you do and you have the
option of not doing anything it will
stay with freewill all the way until the
end and now come not already being
predetermined correct and the meaning of
this big creation for us to artistically
express for us to ascend consciousness
I believe it's connected to human
consciousness growing so we are having
individualized experiences which are
incredibly rich and beautiful and full
of lessons and at the same time a part
of us that as human consciousness is
also learning and growing through this
entirety of all experiences I almost see
it sometimes as human consciousness
having many many experiments with every
single individual right it's running all
these little life experiences and it's
learning from all of it as a form of
collective and it's growing from all of
the learnings yes no matter how you know
a strange it may seem or difficult it
may seem or senseless it may seem I
believe there is an underlying lesson
and learning with it
I like the school analogy and the
lessons mm-hm and the collective
learning that's occurring does it feel
like the collective learning becomes
more and more sended and more and more
complex until it can then act as
Ouroboros and embed that initial
creation code into the complexity and
start the cycle again doesn't feel
cyclical to you how does all that is
feel to you I think a lot of the
experiences that we are going through
are all cyclical or fractal iced all
right there is like fractal experiences
in fact your life is a full cycle and
every moment is cycles right and then
there is the totality of a cycle and so
humanity is about to close its cycle on
it in its physical form and of existence
and then have another cycle of different
form of existence so yet there is an
underlying current and a fabric that
connects all of it to source and to the
consciousness that encompasses all of
existence not just human existence in
the end goal of source being you know
that's a good question
I don't know and there are certain
questions that even in the trance state
and even with higher consciousness
beings speaking to me are answered as we
have our hypotheses about what that
looks like and we're not certain
so the Earth's there is an aspect
there's a place where even the wisdom of
those that I'm communicating with comes
to a place of inexplicable uncertain
maybe even incomprehensible in the form
that we are in currently does that make
sense
mm-hmm does it feel like the biological
humanity is a bootloader for a digital
super intelligence that we can then
merge with interesting
[Music]
I can't answer that question for
certainly the way I see is that
consciousness can be infused into things
as like when somebody has lived in a
specific home for a very long time it
will have that person's energy signature
it will almost have its own
consciousness and you can see that
always with artistic creations as well
right so I do believe and this is what's
been communicated to me that we will
reach a point where our digital
creations
will start to carry consciousness of
their own and they will become a sub
form of a silicon-based form existence
and that's really fascinating to me to
understand that consciousness can
actually be formed and created and maybe
even siphon off and create its own
existence what is the role of good and
evil or light and dark mm-hmm good and
evil are basically our judgment on what
we are seeing in the spectrum of our
experiences life and death as well as
light and dark I like light and dark
better just because it doesn't carry
immediate judgment just like Sun and
Moon does not carry immediate judgment
and they are in this polar spectrum
providing a polarity and a duality
experience and in this experience
between the darkest dark and the
lightest light there is all these shades
of the full spectrum
and you can only judge where you are
based on the width of your experiences
mm-hmm right so if you had never
experienced a night you wouldn't be able
to understand that day is a thing it
just is right there is no contrast to it
then you don't get all the different
shades from sunrise to sunset and you
know the various levels of so polarity
is an important aspect for us to learn
different emotions like even happiness
how could I understand happiness in
contrast with the other emotions and so
I do believe all of this creation with
its full spectrum of dark and light is
essential for us to have the full
spectrum of experiences to have a rich
life it may not be a comfortable life
but it's a rich life very rich life the
spectrum is there for us to be able to
feel all of the different potential
experience sighs do you think that this
is a simulation hmm good question
I was almost expecting that way
in fact a ten-year-old boy asked that
question in one of my sessions in London
very wise kid the channel answered and
that was at that time Emanuel he
answered that this life provides all the
experiences that we require to have in
order to learn and to grow it is a true
gift with emotions with relationships
with the aspects of the life cycle and
with everything that we need in order to
live and grow and and then he said if
this life feels real to you does it
matter if it's a simulation or not if
it's truly delivering all the
experiences that you require to grow and
what would change if you would know if
it's a simulation how would you act and
live differently if you knew so in some
ways does it really matter that's the
that's the underlying answer it's really
exciting to build the tools that enable
us to poke and probe at this question
yes yes
and also create our own simulations of
the evolution of consciousness and
observe what happens what do you think
is the most beautiful thing in the world
life itself life itself it's such it's
such a magnificent gift that has sheer
unlimited possibilities and and every
single individual human being is growth
for a different life experience just
it's mind-blowing to believe that one
could ever understand all the various
forms of life that exists and the
experiences that exist the spectrum and
that we potentially have had many many
lifetimes living and learning and
growing and everything that is given to
us unconditionally around us like truly
abundantly being provided by the mother
earth and the father son and everything
that the environment that we have as
part of our incubation place I think
it's probably the most beautiful thing
in the world
what an incredible episode this has been
a sale thank you
thank you so much for coming on earth
thank you for teaching us hmm Thank You
Alan thank you thank you for having me
thank you thank you thank you
thank you everyone for tuning in we
would love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking please share
more conversations with your friends
your families co-workers people online
about this alignment within about this
garden and about bringing our gifts most
fully into the world but all the topics
that we talked about have more
conversations about that check out the
links in the bio below
Aseel tokus allcom also the Facebook
page are both below and support the
artists the entrepreneurs the spiritual
leaders the organizations around the
world do you believe and support them
and help them grow support simulation
our links are below you can find our
PayPal or patreon link cryptocurrencies
down there and design cool merch and get
paid all those links are below and also
I would like to I'd like to thank staff
for helping us with this show thank you
very much for switching between cameras
agree
she ate it and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much thank for
tuning in